NETFLIX ANIME
We'll make "N-ko Japanese" a regular segment.
"Isn't it awesome?"
Ta-da!
Hi, it's N-ko!
This week's The N-ko Show has started!
Today, I'd like to give you a simple recipe of the breakfast
I've been having lately.
Get three eggs,
break them into a bowl, and whisk.
Then add 150ml of water.
After that, add about two tablespoons of Japanese noodle soup base.
If you haven't got that, please use a little soy sauce instead.
Mix them all together, cover with cling wrap,
heat it in the microwave for about two minutes till it's cooked.
That's been my breakfast lately.
(What will you get from that?)
Then you'll have fluffed egg, like savory steamed egg custard.
I love steamed egg custard and pudding,
so I'm having healthy breakfasts like that lately.
Please do try it yourselves.
Well then, let's start this week's The N-ko Show!
We had done this as a special segment before,
but we're going to make it a regular one.
Please use it as a reference to help you say some famous lines in Japanese.
I'm going to speak in English from here.
This week's quotes will be from...
MISS KOBAYASHI'S DRAGON MAID Season 2 has started airing
in summer of 2021.
The first quote is...
"I will pick where I belong."
So this quote is...
Basically, it's saying that Tohru has the freedom
to choose wherever she goes as she pleases.
So, "I will pick where I belong."
So "I will choose where I belong" is basically the translation.
"Isn't it really awesome?"
And to pronounce it like Kanna-chan...
And this phrase is used a lot in Japanese as well,
so anytime you think of, you think something is "wow",
or you think something is "whoa", it's kind of like "wow".
"Isn't it really awesome?"
Oh, "Isn't it really awesome?"
I hope this tutorial helps you guys
to pronounce these two very famous quotes from MISS KOBAYASHI'S DRAGON MAID.
Please try to use them in your daily life.
That's it for N-ko's Japanese.
The N-ko Show! It's now time to say goodbye.
This time, in N-ko's Japanese,
I introduced anime quotes you can use in daily life,
and I also told you how to make the breakfast I'm lately addicted to.
Please do use them in your daily life.
Let's meet again next time!
See you!
NETFLIX ANIME